la soledad se apodera de algunas calles
de sudán en el tercer día de huelga
civil médicos pilotos y trabajadores de
las estaciones petroleras se sumaron al
movimiento que rechaza la toma del poder
por parte de los militares del país la
tensa situación ha llevado a que muchos
se resguarden en sus hogares
como empleado del sector privado
actualmente estoy en la casa y lo he
estado por 48 horas desde que comenzó la
huelga civil porque las protestas en las
calles tenían pancartas y cánticos que
la anunciaban múltiples negocios
cerraron desde que el ejército
encarcelar a al primer ministro de la
anp doc y acabará con la transición
democrática que vivía el país desde 2019
una manguera diaria los centros
comerciales bancos e instituciones
gubernamentales y empresas privadas
están cerrados es una huelga civil total
y la gente se está preparando para el
evento principal el 30 de octubre
la aparente calma se ve interrumpida por
múltiples personas que construyen
barricadas y bloquean las calles se
espera una multitudinaria manifestación
el sábado paralelamente las reacciones
internacionales continúan el
representante de sudán ante la onu pidió
continuar con el apoyo hacia la nación
africana mientras que el consejo de
seguridad condenó el golpe el banco
mundial- detuvo los pagos y las
operaciones en sudán un duro revés para
la ya golpeada economía del país que
dependía de dichos fondos para la
financiación de grandes proyectos de
desarrollo